so I'm gonna ask to give a very
impromptu talk unfortunately the speaker
for the slot was not able to make it I
had some prepared talks ready for you
guys but these are talks have given
quite a number of times in the past and
after a while you get tired of them so
if you really want to see a generators
talk we can pull that out or if you'd
really like to see an embedding talking
pull that out but I can give you a
couple of small pieces that usually make
their way into lightning talks but if
we're lucky we can extend to fill the
time allotted that's me speaking very
slowly to fill all my time so one thing
that I like to do in my spare time is
hack around with cpython
and I know that we're told that pi PI is
the wave of the future that pi pi is
where pythons going one thing that I
find a little bit disappointing about pi
PI is that as an interpreter it's a
little it's a lot harder to understand
what's going on internally this is a
problem that I found what C++ I started
off as a C++ programmer this is what I
studied in school and one of my first
jobs I was hired as a C++ programmer it
was during that job that I transitioned
into Python in that experience I found
that you would often be given a piece of
code where there was some interaction
between two or three features maybe
you're using operator overloading you're
using some advanced features placement
new or our value references or I can't
even remember all the features that are
available in C++ 11 and now C++ 17 but
there's some strange interaction between
the features and as a consequence of
those interactions the code just kind of
falls over it does something very
unexpected this happened a lot with
interactions between say templating and
virtual tables and operator overloading
and I'm sure we've all been in a
situation like that where you get this
error from your compiler and it's
absolutely and totally inscrutable and
your entire supposed to be able to
understand how these features interact
and you're supposed to have some tools
in order to determine what went wrong in
order to be able to make a convincing
argument that this is what went wrong
and if we make these small changes or
these fixes here we can take broken code
and make it work in code
and I found that the way that when I was
done in C++ was somewhat unsatisfying to
me in one sense we were I think a little
bit too reliant on documentation C++ is
a language with a formal spec and so
we're supposed to be able to rely on the
specification in order to tell us what's
right and what's wrong even though the
specification in many cases has you know
large gaps in it if you go on a Stack
Overflow and you look at some of the
harder C++ questions there you'll see
there's one gentleman from believe
Germany a young kid from Germany who has
memorized you know line and section
every part of the C++ spec and can
recite it for you if you have some
question about interaction between these
two features and can just you know like
you'd see in a courtroom drama go down
to the nitty-gritty details of what each
specific term means and some some
context one thing that's nice about
Python is that it has a reference of
limitation and we're told that the
disadvantage of a reference
implementation is that it always over
specifies that there's some behavior
that the reference implementation has
where this isn't documented behavior and
may not be intentional behavior
well one nice thing about that is you
can at least come up with meaningful
from Lisa an engineering perspective
meaningful conclusions about the way the
code works and this is something that's
very nice about Python and something
that I always had a little bit of
difficulty with with pi PI for example
if we go into the you know the first
time I downloaded the source code for pi
PI I had somebody look like this and I
tried to figure out where is the actual
pi PI compiler what are the steps or can
I put a breakpoint to just figure things
out and I was at a loss in fact I had to
do something like tree to figure out
where all these or the actual code was
located and identifying how these files
correlated to the actual steps in the
compilation process was non-trivial this
is just the consequence of pi PI being a
very sophisticated tool and so naturally
there's gonna be a learning curve one
thing that's very nice about C Python is
that we can see it's a very practical
interpreter for everyday use I'm sure
many of us in the room are actually
using C Python in production and it also
turns out to be an interpreter that is
exceptionally easy for you to get into
for you to understand how it works if
you to understand the mechanics of for
you to just start with no knowledge
whatsoever cpython and just set a
breakpoint and figure out what's going
on internally so I will give you the
actual process that I took when getting
into C Python the first thing I did was
I went to python.org and I downloaded
one of the tar balls or the source code
and I unzipped it you can see these are
all the C pythons I have here and we'll
choose the latest one they have
installed so we'll do everything based
on three point five and let's see do I
have this built yes I have this built
very good so what I did was I built it
from source and the C Python build
system is pretty straightforward it uses
auto confidante of tools and make pretty
straightforward and actually one of the
reasons where one of the things that
drew me to Python was I was dealing with
a very large C++ trade system it was a
system that was in practice absolutely
an asset for the firm it could be used
from the front office all the way to the
mid office to the back office you know
we had complete transparency over the
numbers that were been generated for P&L
the pricing that the front office did
for its financial instruments was
exactly the same pricing that the
settlements team could use in order to
determine proceeds to determine how much
money entered and left the firm and we
could actually tie out P&L and position
numbers from what the front office saw
what was sent up to senior management
with exactly what was in the bank
account so it was a beautiful system but
one unfortunate thing was it was a large
amount of C++ that had grown over about
15 years with large teams of distributed
developers so the build system had this
one hiccup and we've all seen which is
you build it you type your make - j9 and
then it doesn't work and you're told
oh it just doesn't work the first pass
so just try it again and suddenly on the
second pass it works and you can think
isn't that absurd so one of the things
that really drew me to Python the first
time was I type make and the build for
Python is just a bunch of GCC calls
building objects it was just the
simplest most straightforward build
process that I'd seen for an application
of considerable size there's a lot of C
code and C Python I mean we can see
there's quite a bit I've see here and I
did something just like this I did
I did I did a count of the number of
lines and I saw that the number of lines
and cpython in comparison to number of
lines that my business student had
written were comparable except the
quality was much better just some of the
operational characteristics of building
it and maintaining the code was much
better so anyway I had downloaded this
code I built it and I started a Python
interpreter so we have a Python
interpreter here and I had known about
this module in Python called dis and
after I got over the juvenile giddiness
of writing code like this no nobody
there's an impromptu joke come on Kabam
at least at least i can do this and
you'll laugh no nobody remembers the 90s
okay anyway so there's this module in
Python called dis and what this gives
you is disassembly of a Python function
gives you the byte code and this is the
first thing that I was looking into and
the byte code is very easy to read if
you have some function called double and
it takes some value and it returns the
value doubled you can disassemble it and
you can see the by car and if we look
through the byte code I don't know if
there's very good documentation of what
all the columns here mean but the first
column here is the line number the
second column is the offset into the
byte code to the byte code if you look
at it it's just this binary combination
of opcodes and so this is the actual
offset into that then the third one is
the interpretation of the OP code then
the fourth column is the argument that
it's passed and this is an
interpretation of the argument so you
can see in my function that doubles two
things I load X I load a constant to
this X is loaded fast which means it's
loaded from some local storage and then
I call this OP code binary multiply and
I return about you and what I did to get
into C Python was literally I saw this
binary multiply thing and I did this I
crept for it in the source code I didn't
read any documentation I was like many
programmers to impatience to read up
documentation I
wanted to just dive in so I literally
went into the source code and I grabbed
tort and I did one thing slightly more
smartly than normal I knew is in a C
file so I just grabbed through all C
files because you know if you grep
through you're gonna get matches it to
binaries and matches into documentation
and that's not what you're looking for
so I crept for binary multiplying all
the zeros and end up with five hits and
if we look at the five hits who can
probably guess what they are compiled at
C is probably the Python compiler it's
probably what takes text and turns it
into byte codes peephole dot C well that
could be a lot of things you could let
your imagination run wild but it's
probably a peephole optimizer we know
that for a byte code you can look at
small sections to buy how to do small
optimizations on it and the last one c
eval dot c and the word eval and there
is very suggestive so if we look in to
see eval dot c and this actually used to
be a lot clearer in Python 2 before they
added some of the macros but in Python 2
or in Python 3 if we go for a binary
multiply we'll see in the sieve I'll not
see on line 1495 there is this target
thing and in Python 2 there there wasn't
this target macro they implemented this
kind of thing that term of art is direct
threading interpreter something that if
you google for you'll see a nice
discussion of it by the guy who wrote
Lua Jet Mike Paul and how this gives you
more cache friendly interpreters but
what these targets are actually just
switch or just case statements in a big
switch statement so what you have here
is just a giant for loop that's going
over every opcode then a switch
statement that switches for every opcode
and then a case statement to handle a
talker and that's just about the most
basic structure you could think of for
an interpreter this is pretty much all
there is to the C Python interpreter and
I found this to be extremely refreshing
and very empowering because with just a
little bit of work and a little bit of
knowledge I was able to get a foothold
into what's a fairly complex system C
Python so the next thing that I did was
let's go to our binary multiply I just
put a breakpoint here so I loaded up my
Python in my Python interpreter to gdb
a breakpoint on line let's say 1 4 9 6
so let's do that
gdb
what I want so let's run our Python
interpreter we can see a Python
interpreter here we'll write our
function well ctrl C to break into this
and we'll put a breakpoint and see wow
that's C 1496 with the line there we go
and we'll continue our Python
interpreter then we'll call our double
function on a value and you can see
we've broken right into and if we do
list we can see all the code that we
recognized and here we can start
stepping through the code base and as we
step through the code base or if we look
at the back trace we can see some very
very simple things now if we want to get
a little bit ahead of ourselves a little
bit more sophisticated
we'll have noticed that there's a tools
directory and C Python source code and
there's a gdb directory in there and
there's a file called Lib Python dot P
why that makes your life in gdb much
easier now remember at the time I had
almost no experience using gdb almost
all of my experience doing anything
lower level than C I came from actually
came from interacting with C Python I
learned everything I know about gdb
interacting with C Python but everything
I know about assembly interacting with C
Python which probably isn't the best
marketing pitch for learn Python learn
Python you'll get a lot of experience
with assembly but this happens to be my
area of interest well you can see we can
do BT and that gives us a back trace and
what that tells us is the stack frames
that go all the way to the beginning so
it gives us a lot of really useful and
very interesting information for example
one thing that I always like to do when
I'm trying to analyze some code is find
the entry point and you can actually see
the entry point for Python is a main
function in Python C that calls PI main
that calls this that cause that that
calls this and you can see interactive
loop flags and if we go to the top of
this we can see that something ended up
calling this function called pi eval
frame X sorry pi eval codex sorry pi
eval frame X which is where your where
your interpreter was and you can see
this was a result of a fast function
call so that was my double call then
ended up trying to interpret the byte
codes that implement the double function
in PI UFL frame X that said if I can
split the screen here and look at
my Python interpreter side-by-side look
at the code base side by side with gotta
have tag setup we can actually step
through this very easily and see Python
interpreter is written to be changed
very easily it's written for you to be
able to modify it very easily for it to
be a playground for language
implementers and maintain errs and so it
doesn't the labor optimizations I built
that you know outside of the
optimizations that are available in
peephole and outside of some very
reasonable optimizations like instance
method caching the interpreter is pretty
straightforward so we can actually step
through this and see all the steps that
are involved in doing something as
simple as multiplying a value times two
now bear in mind multiplying a value
times two is not as simple as it sounds
because in my code i said x times two
and that x times two could be anything
times two
it could be a integer times two it could
be a float times two it could be a
string times two it could be a custom
object x - it could be an umpire and the
array x - and each one of those will
have very very different code baths
and very different consequences so let's
see how this gets dispatched so if we do
a and i'm going to do this with a little
bit of knowledge already because i know
which ones to step into and which ones
to step over so don't worry too much
about that but at the worst case when i
did this for the very first time it was
just a very tedious i'd step into every
function and it took me a couple of days
to really get a hold of it but there was
no difficulty involved it was just the
time and the finding the time to do it
and having enough interest and passion
to it so i can step into pi number
multiply and so we can see something
very interesting from the overall
structure of python every one of these
high-level op codes has a corresponding
PI object or PI number call so for
binary multiply its PI number multiplied
and you can see that there is at the sea
level an API that reflects directly the
syntax of the language so if we're in PI
number multiply which is this code here
you can see immediately how we handle
the situation between
p-ting and between actual multiplication
so you can see that there's some code
here for determining if we have a
sequence and whether we're doing some
repeating of a sequence such as
multiplying a string or multiplying a
list times two versus some other
operation you can see that the sequence
is handled differently so first it's
going to try and perform this binary
option which will try and dispatch to
say the long multiply or the float
multiply or some custom multiply that
you that you have implemented on your
object and so we can step into this and
we end up in this code over here and
then as you go through you can start
answering some very simple questions for
yourself so one question is always if we
have a mole and an our mole implemented
on two objects and there are subtypes of
each other or there's some relationship
between the two types which one gets
called obviously if we do two primitive
types multiplied times each other
that operation is is clear but what if
we have two custom types multiplied
times each other and they both implement
this multiplication protocol which one
gets called and you can see the dispatch
for that pretty clearly in the code and
you can see from the code there's not a
lot of knowledge of C necessary in order
to understand this you basically have to
understand that the arrow means look up
a field there's almost no dot notation
because everything's passed around as a
PI object pointer and then you have to
be able to you know appreciate that
there may be macros and so you have to
look up those macros and a couple of C
isms like for example when you and your
Python if you do hash of two it gives
you two and if you think your hash of
negative two it gives you negative two
you do hash of one it gives you one need
to hash of negative one it gives you
negative two and that should be
immediately obvious with just a little
bit of understanding of some C isms
which is clearly or most likely behind
the scenes this negative one is being
used as some error value and so some of
those C isms may be necessary in order
to understand the C Python code base but
it's a fairly low bar to entry here and
you can see when you read through this
code it's pretty straightforward there
checking to see if
one of them's a subtype of the other one
and if the method on that is implemented
and we can keep stepping until we
actually find this bachelor method and
this is one way that I started to answer
some very practical questions that
people came up to me with about what
happens at sea Python
things like if I have two objects with
these subtype relationships which one
gets called or when I overload this
particular data mountain model method
what happens or when I try and do
something like an import hook how does
that work and these questions can be
answered for you very easily from C
Python just by reading through the code
and always found those to be extremely
satisfying answers much more satisfying
answers than the kind of answers I come
up with with C++ because in some case
what C++ they'd say well why did this
code do this and have to either read
through the spec or try to infer from
the behavior or at the most what I'd
have to do is I'd look at the C++ and
I'd look at some emitted assembly and
I'd say well I can kind of refer that
between the C++ and this assembly some
steps happened but it's very rare I
think in practice for somebody to
actually do GCC - yes and omit all the
steps of all the optimization and
everything that happens in the
compilation process and actually step
through that and say well at this
particular line and your compiler this
this and this happens and that's not the
nature of how C++ exists as a language
that's not how people are supposed to
talk about C++ but I kind of liked in
Python you could talk about it that way
I could say well the behavior of for
example a common thing that comes up is
when you put methods into a week
dictionary or if you put methods into a
into a into if you take week references
of instance methods what happens and
there's a potential bug around there
because you might lose access to methods
because there's this method cache you
could look into see Python and you can
see where their method cache happens and
you can say usually confidently that at
least in my execution environment we're
going to be standardized on C Python so
what happens in C Python is the truth
for this circumstance and you can give a
very clear you can very quickly and very
effectively give a very straightforward
answer to these kind of questions one
that's grounded in some fundamental
truth
where that fundamental truth is this is
actually what's happening and I found
that to be much more satisfying than
saying well the spec says this and we're
just hoping that the compiler ought
implementer is implemented it correctly
and if they didn't this this and this
happens but beyond that there was no
gradual stepping between what you were
able to do and what you wanted to
explain in the C++ world it seemed like
there is a very sharp cliff where you
had to be almost a compiler expert to be
able to answer some things whereas in
Python you can always step down a little
bit in your comfort level you could
start with byte code and then go down to
C Python internals and then if you chose
go down a little bit deeper the other
thing that you could do with this is you
can start implementing some fairly neat
things and once you spend I would say
maybe a couple of weeks just playing
around inside C Python just by setting
breakpoints and understanding how things
work you can start to implement some
fairly sophisticated features that
actually don't take a lot of code to
implement so I'll show you two examples
of them these are two things that I've
given you know short lightning talks
about these were just things I did for
fun one of them was this topic of a
custom literals comes up all the time
you know we have a literal expression
for Strings we have a literal expression
for numbers one for sets and
dictionaries and sometimes people say
well couldn't we add our own literal
expression for custom types and you can
think well what does that mean
and there's even a question of what's
the difference between this there's a
semantic difference between this and
this and what is the semantic difference
between the two of these well the
semantic difference is more or less that
there's an operational difference and
that this actually calls a function
called dict with arguments and this one
is actually implemented in a byte in a
piece of byte code but there's a
semantic difference here and that at
some point in code somebody could do
something awful like that and if they
did something like that then your code
may have very dramatic behavior whereas
using the literal syntax would not
actually be affected by this literal
syntax is saying construct a literal and
I don't care about what the binding of
these built-in functions
in practice nobody does things like that
so the distinction is usually lost but
it does exist so if you think about it
in that sense that you might say well
literal syntax is just the ability for
us to call functions at compile time and
we can do that in Python except the
compiler in Python is very very small
Python compiler doesn't really do a
whole lot it just takes source text it
builds a symbol table it tries to infer
the location of variables and then it
emits bytecode and it doesn't really do
a lot of work there but one thing that
you can do is you can play around with
how evaluation works and if you think
about the evaluation of some Python code
there's a module there's a piece of
module level code and then inside that
you have classes and functions and
there's these different runtime scopes
so what you could think of as an
equivalent to increasing what you can do
a compile time is you can start moving
code into the earlier parts of runtime
and so I wrote a little bit code to do
that didn't take a lot of time it took a
couple days to do this which looks
something like this
so if you have a function and it returns
a string times 10 this is a constant
expression and in some cases the C
Python interpreter is smart enough to be
able to take constant expressions and
calculate them so if these were two
integers it would actually just emit in
the byte code the actual multiplication
of two integers but in the case of
slightly more complex ones it's not
smart enough to do that so every time
I'm calling this function I'm
multiplying this string times this
number even though the result will
always be the same and within the
semantics of C Python there's absolutely
no way for this result to be anything
but asdf times 10 there's no way for me
from the Python lair to overload any of
those operations so the result is really
always strictly asdf times 10 there's
it's a it is a strictly constant
expression there's no Oh what if I
overload this overload that not in this
case so you can see there's something
missing there well I was able to add
this piece of syntax to eagerly eval any
expression so what this does is it
eagerly evaluates expression one runtime
frame up so you can see here when I
disassemble its evaluated the expression
one level higher than the definition and
stored as a constant and you could think
you could do some neat things with this
it's a fairly obscure thing that adds
some very strange to the language but
there are some kind of neat things you
can do for example if you had some wrap
around SQL types and you wanted to do
something like something like that so
some wrap around that in your code just
to make sure that every time you typed
an SQL statement something was correct
maybe the table existed or those SQL
statements well formatted it wasn't just
a string then you might do something
like this in this case you can see I'm
doing a very simple thing I'm just
making sure that the only valid SQL
statements are insert statements
otherwise it's gonna fail well with this
I could do something that looks like
this
so this is often what our code looks
like the actual part of the code that we
might want to determine at runtime is
Ness it's nested a couple of functions
deep or a couple of classes deep a
couple of scopes deep and I have an
error but I'll only ever see this error
some at runtime I'll only ever see this
error where I call the wrapper function
that's constructed within the bar
function that requires an instance of
the foo class and so you can see I have
an error lurking in the code but if you
can lift that evaluation up then then it
makes things a little bit easier and so
I added one more which lifts it up to
module scope and lifts it all the way up
and you can see the assertion areas call
so what you can do is you can lift the
evaluation of statements up so you can
do things like checking constants kind
of neat and I'll show you one more that
people seem to like a lot better than
that one I like this one even though the
semantics are a little bit weird
they ASD expression so hopefully I have
a build of this that works this one is
really a testament to how easy it is to
modify C Python what's giving a talk in
November and I wanted to show some
internals of Python stuff just as a
quick example I had a conversation with
a gentleman named Matthew Rocklin and
he'd been complaining about how in
libraries like numb expert you have to
pass expression to strings he hated that
and I said you know if you wanted to you
could probably spend less than five
hundred lines of code in less than four
hours getting this done so it's 3 a.m.
I'm in a hotel or this is in London so
I'm in the closest approximation to a
hotel that fit my budget yeah and I
putting my slides together and I say
okay let me give it a try three hours
later I have this working so it's kind
of neat I have the ability you can add
the ability to encode as literals X
little syntax expressions so you have
something like this this represents the
addition of x and y and let's do one
that's a little bit more complicated X
plus X plus y you can bind this to a
variable and then you can fill in X or
you can fill in Y or you can fill in X
and why
and they can evaluate it and you can
start to do some really neat things
outside of simplifying the syntax for
something like sim pie or something like
num expert you can do some really neat
things with this like this here we
combined the operation of a function
being called on two arguments with the
arguments swamped 2i syntax tree and
then we can fill in strict values for x
and y and one thing I can show you is
that you can always fill this in with
another tree so you can build trees
really nicely really easily there we go
and then we can fill in all those values
and the only thing that we have that's
unbound is actually the function so we
can fill in the function with an add and
call it with a mole and call it or with
a Sabich all kind of neat and it's a
kind of neat way of building expressions
and this took me four hundred lines of
code in about three hours and put into
the Python interpreter now I'm not
saying the code is very good but it is a
testament to how easy it is to play with
and modify the C Python interpreter so
that's my impromptu talk trying to
encourage all of you to look into this
layer that sometimes we ignore and to
encourage you to see this as something
that's actually very easy and very open
for you to explore and understand you
don't have to have any knowledge coming
into it in fact all of the C that you
need to know in order to understand what
happens in C Python you could probably
learn from a 10-minute tutorial on C
it's very straightforward code and it's
there written in such a fashion as to be
understood and manipulated by average
people I hope you enjoyed that impromptu
talk
I'm James Powell thanks so much
you